you know I'd like to First offer Nina
Nina okay Chica Chica this looks
terrible I'm not even gonna lie to you
like this looks horrible
um however I will say there's two sides
to every story so chick if you want to
come on I'm a fair interviewer you saw
me with Brittany Renner I didn't I
didn't Corner her I wasn't I I'm pretty
polite I'm pretty nice if you wanna come
on and give your side of the story you
know I I think everyone should be able
to give their side but this looks pretty
bad so um
Nina Agdal filed a lawsuit against Dylan
danis Dylan danis has acclaimed in a
post that he is facing a massive lawsuit
from Nina Agdal Logan Paul's girlfriend
he posted Nina Agdal has filed a massive
lawsuit against me she filed a
restraining order against me and is
seeking prison time so the fight is in
Jeopardy if I'm in jail this is actually
wild but I won't stop F the system come
get me Logan Paul is a Dead Man Walking
wow
now I actually have a question because I
was thinking about this I had a Twitter
poll if someone sues does that mean the
person's telling the truth and because I
was thinking like if someone says a wild
story and it's not true and you sue do
you guys think
like people are more likely to sue if
it's truer if it's not true
um I I pulled people and it was like 50
50. so I'm not really sure but
um okay so then Dylan danis also tweeted
gotta F them all wow
Nina's lawyer right now uh Dylan danda
says I didn't even put a ring on it and
she's already trying to F me for all my
money
um Dylan Dana says Nina Agdal will be
called Karen AG doll to further notice
also guys had a question if she's gonna
marry Rich anyway why is she suing
because apparently this could
hypothetically put him in jail and I
think she's gonna file a restraining
order so I think that would impact the
fight so my question is she's single now
uh because I mean Logan's the one that's
been saying that he's done this all for
clout the publicity so he can make money
off the fight why would she jeopardize
the fight if that's the case
maybe she's single I don't know Nina
Nina come on uh what's the next one oh
no
you're doing amazing sweetie
oh dear imagine the years and years of
content that will be produced after
Dylan is legally allowed to gather
Discovery
oh I didn't think of that L Nina Agdal
Al Logan Paul I think the real reason
the guys are outraged I gotta be honest
as they look at Logan and they see okay
this is a guy that is
um attractive he's jacked he's
um clearly smart right he's a good
marketer good podcast so he's got
everything he's got clout money status
and if he can't get a chick that's not a
[__] what does that mean for you a lot
of you are clowning him right now right
I'm just I'm just being honest guys a
lot of you are clowning him
um and the difference is your wife it
just wasn't pictured you know what I
mean like I again I'm not trying to be
an [__] but this is this is what the
guys are are thinking they're like Okay
so this guy's got everything and even he
couldn't avoid a [__]
what is that what does that mean for me
I'm not it's jacked handsome or smart
so you know I I really am this is my
open invite Nina Logan I'm a nice chick
you know I'll be nicer than really any
other interviewer I think like who I was
pretty nice to Brittany Renner right I
was not you know so I'll give you guys a
fair interview I really think there's
two sides to every story so if you guys
want to call in one of these days let's
let's set it up